Speaker 1: Well, this is an interesting turn
of events. Lying. Republican Congressman
elect George Santos is now under criminal
investigation. You've got to love it. You know,
I was thinking back to earlier this
week when he first addressed his lies.
The thing he was hanging on to was, I haven't
done anything criminal. Remember this clip?
Speaker 2: I'm not a criminal. Not here. Not
abroad, in any jurisdiction in the world.
Have I ever committed any crimes? To get
down to the nitty gritty. I'm not a fraud.
I'm not a criminal who defrauded the entire
country and made up this fictional character.
Speaker 1: Well, fictitious, novel or fictitious
or whatever word you want to use. It turns out
maybe there is some criminality. AP reports New
York Representative elect Santos investigated
for lying about his past. He is now under
investigation by Long Island prosecutors
after revelations surfaced that he lied about
his heritage, his education and his professional
pedigree as he was campaigning. He has shown
no signs of stepping aside, even as he publicly
admitted to a long list of lies. Nassau County
District Attorney Anne Donnelly, a Republican,
said the fabrications and inconsistencies were
nothing short of stunning. Saying, quote, The
residents of Nassau County and other parts of the
third District must have an honest and accountable
representative in Congress. If a crime was
committed in this county, we will prosecute it.
What would so remember lied about his employment
history, lied about his educational history,
lied about being Jewish, apparently told the truth
about being gay. And later, I'm going to tell you,
he apparently lied about his mom dying in 911.
We're going to get to that. That's a whole
other sick ordeal. So how could this be a crime?
Yes. In a normal job where you're not voted in,
if you lied in this way to human resources, you
would be fired. You would be let go. But this is
different. How could this be a crime? In this
particular situation, fraud is the most likely
charge. So lying about one's educational and
employment history can be considered fraud if
it's done with the intention of obtaining a job or
other benefits. It's abundantly clear because he
said it in an interview, because of the elitist
New York Times not valuing his customer service
experience. He almost had no choice but to
claim to have worked for Goldman Sachs and
graduated from a college he didn't graduate from.
He was almost forced into it. So he's essentially
saying in order to get this job, in order to get
the type of coverage I need and to get voted in,
I embellished, as he calls it. We call it straight
up line that meets the definition of fraud,
lying in order to obtain a job or other benefits.
And by the way, it's taxpayer dollars that go
to pay his salary and those benefits. That's the
most likely charge now. In other situations, lying
about your education or employment history, if you
do it under oath, you're talking about perjury,
right? If you do it in a court case, could be
considered perjury and then could have legal
consequences, discrimination if you lie about your
religion, as he did, and then that is somehow used
to discriminate or gain an unfair advantage in
certain situations, then it can be against the law
and then misrepresentation. If you lie about your
employment history or your educational history,
if it's done with the intent of misleading
others, it can lead to legal consequences,
including fine and imprisonment. Whether that
would be the case in this particular situation,
I really can't say. We're kind of getting ahead
of ourselves. But there's one other aspect to
the possible criminality, and it relates to
some campaign loans. George Santos's massive
campaign loans may not be legal, reports The
Daily Beast. And here's the deal with that.
There are. He loaned his campaign $700,000. It's
not clear how he did it. And as the article says
it, it's been a bit of a mystery. But depending
on how that was done, that also could actually
be a violation of campaign finance law. And the
article explains it in detail. The Daily Beast
has part of an answer the identities of four of
Santos's corporate clients. The revelation puts
him in more hot water. What he did with the
money he obtained could be even more damning.
Santos has admitted using cash from his company
to fund his campaign. That could be an unlawful
$700,000 corporate contribution. That's because
while candidates for federal office may give
unlimited amounts of their own money to their
campaign, they cannot expressly tap corporate
accounts to do so. So that also may be a criminal
aspect to this entire thing. Criminal is one part.
My hope is that all of this gets him to resign
and say that he will not. Be seated. Which is
scheduled to happen next week. We're running
out of time. Republicans may be put. Democrats
plan to object. From what I'm reading, Democrat
Democrats are going to object to his being sworn
in. What that will lead to is a vote on whether
he should or shouldn't be sworn in. Republicans,
of course, will have the majority in that new
Congress, but it will put every single one of
them in a position of having to vote yes.
This liar fraudster should be seated or not.
That could get very interesting.
We'll know more about that next week